إذا قمت بتكبير الصورة الآن على ما يحدث الآن
لقد كنا داخل غزة منذ عدة أيام
في القتال ضد حماس
ونقول أننا اليوم في حدود 80% من المساحة
في سيطرتنا، هناك حاجة إلى 20٪ أخرى للعمل على أوراق الزيتون
ومحيطها شمال قطاع غزة تتكلم نعم
فى الشمال
الشريط هو النقطة
السبب الرئيسي الذي من أجله ذهبنا إلى الحرب هو القضاء على
الخمسة
وجين، لسوء الحظ، نحن بعيدون جدًا هنا
ماهيد لأنه تم بناء مدينة الأنفاق تحت الشريط
غزة تحت غزة أيضا تحت مواقف السيارات بعد ذلك
سنتحدث عما سيحدث
هناك عشرات الآلاف هناك
الإرهابيون الذين يجرون أرقامًا لعدد القتلى لم يدخلوا
ولهذا أشعر أن الحبر بين ما يقال وما
ما حدث بالفعل ليس دقيقًا تمامًا
مطلقة لكننا سنتركها ولو كانت بضعة آلاف
قتل لديهم عشرات الآلاف من يتجولون
في الأنفاق أدناه هذا هو الغرض الرئيسي
نصل إليهم ونؤذيهم وإذا وصلنا إلى حد ما
هذا لا
تمكنا من الوصول إلى معظمهم لذلك نحن حقا
بعيدًا جدًا عن القصة، سأعطيك المثال فقط
آخر واحد أمس
وتم إطلاق سراح مختطفينا من مكان ما في قلب المنطقة
لقد انتصرنا بالفعل داخل غزة، وهم يغادرون
ويجد المئذنة مختطفين حولهم العشرات من الأشخاص
مئات الزيتون
الذين يصرخون ويرفعون المخطوف في قلب المكان
أننا بالفعل فيه على سيارات الإسعاف
الصليب الأحمر الذي ينطلق ونحن المانحون
وبث أننا في السيطرة
في الوضع وهذا حتى قبل أن نبدأ في المنطقة كثيرًا
والأصعب أمامنا هو قضية هانيو
وسنتحدث عنها أكثر
القليل من التحقق من بعض هذه الأنفاق
والتي هي أقل من تلك التي من المتوقع أن تتأثر اليوم
20% الآن ما يتأثر لا ندخله
الجنود في الأنفاق ووصفهم على هذا النحو
يمكن أن يكون محاصرا، لا تريد تعريض الناس للخطر بعد ذلك
لدينا الوحدات الهندسية التي تقوم بتفجير
الأعمدة ما يفجر العمود يسد
وقيل إن دخوله قد جعل من العروس 200300 عندهم
الآلاف منهم، حتى لو قمت بسد عمود
لا يزال لديهم الكثير من النقاط
التي يمكن أن يخرجوا منها، أي أنهم سوف يلخصون
قصة ال
أجرؤ على إدراك أننا بعيدون جدًا عن الهدف
الرئيسي
لنا